[Music]
hello friends
and welcome to i'd like to know some tv
and we are taking your bible questions
this is the time that we give to you for
those questions that you send in that
you have about the bible old testament
new testament whatever it is
and we are interested in helping you to
answer those questions
if we can and of course we have a number
of questions today that have come in
that we're going to be looking at
but if you'd like to send in a question
that you have
you can send that to tv at some tv.org
that's
tv sumtv.org we'd love to hear from you
we'd love to hear your questions
and we'd love to try to answer those
questions for you from the bible
all right before we get started we
should have a word of prayer and then
we'll jump right in
okay father in heaven we thank you now
that we're able to open your word
to answer some questions we ask for the
guidance of your holy spirit
i ask that you will bless all of those
who are watching this program
and that the answers we provide will be
in harmony with your holy word
thank you father for the privilege of
coming to you in prayer
thank you for giving us your wisdom
because we ask it in the
jesus name amen amen amen all right so
we have some
long questions and some short questions
today uh the first one
actually comes in relationship to easter
easter weekend is the weekend that is uh
uh i would say it's you know got a lot
of uh
pagan roots um but the main routes that
we as christians attach it to
is the the the death and the
resurrection of jesus christ
and so we differentiate that from the
word itself
and the question comes in in
relationship to uh easter and good
friday what we what we call good friday
i'd like to say what catholics call good
friday because i was raised catholic and
that's a very catholic phrase
so i think this viewer may be coming in
from that perspective they're asking the
question
why seventh-day adventist church why
does the seventh-day adventist church
not commemorate
good friday is there something wrong to
go to church on good friday thank you
for responding
to my question okay uh probably i can
make two points
point number one no place does the bible
mandate
celebrating holy week so-called
uh it's a tradition that has come into
the christian church
very early but there's no place in the
new testament that says that we're
supposed to celebrate
any of the things of um of the week of
the passion
with the exception probably of the
lord's supper
which commemorates the death of jesus
until he comes according to the bible
and what i find amazing is that
christians will observe things that are
not commanded in scripture
whereas the sabbath which is directly
commanded in scripture they say
well that one doesn't apply so you know
it makes you wonder you know why they
celebrate what the bible doesn't
uh say that we're supposed to celebrate
but that which the bible explicitly
repeatedly everywhere
says we're supposed to observe the
seventh-day sabbath
they don't another issue that i have
with
holy week is you know every event in the
catholic church of holy week is
celebrated yearly except for
resurrection
uh that's interesting you know palm
sunday they only celebrate once a year
okay uh you know uh wednesday mm-hmm
uh thursday holy thursday as it's called
early friday you know they celebrate
those yearly
but when it comes to the resurrection
well we're going to do that every week
why it's a human tradition that is not
based on what the bible teaches
in other words when you say every week
you mean going to church on sunday
because of the resurrection yeah
yeah but they don't celebrate all the
other events like holy week
right on a weekly basis it's only sunday
that's a good point that's a really good
point you know
my immediate answer this question was
something you just brought up and that's
first corinthians chapter 11. i thought
we might be able to read those verses
just because i think they'd be good for
the viewer
to understand in the context because we
as adventists
are our number one fundamental belief is
the bible the word of god that's our num
that's our when you look at our 28
fundamentals the word of god is number
one amen so we always go to the word of
god
so when you're asking okay why don't we
go to church on good friday that's the
day that christ
died well we go to the word of god and
we want to follow what
christ's instruction was for us
concerning that concerning commemorating
that
so in first corinthians chapter 11
beginning with verse
23 paul says for i have received
the lord that which also i delivered
unto you so this is something he got
directly from jesus and now he's
delivering it to the church
that the lord jesus the same night in
which he was betrayed this is the night
that he's betrayed and the next day he's
you know crucified and dies
when he had given thanks he he took
bread and when he had given thanks
he break it and he said take eat this is
my body which is broken for you do this
in remembrance of me
after the same manner also he took the
cup
and when he stopped saying this cup is
the new testament in my blood this do ye
as oft as you drink it in remembrance of
me and then verse 26 and here's the
clincher
for as often as you eat this bread and
drink this cup
you do show the lord's death till he
come so the bible says the way we
commemorate the lord's death
is the last supper right you know
tradition the church etc
so i would say yeah the reason why we
don't go to church or
celebrate good friday or commemorate
good friday is because we're following
the bible and this is the way the bible
tells us to commemorate good friday
right
i don't i i wouldn't say it's wrong for
someone to go to church on friday or
wednesday or tuesday or any other day
only as you said pastor if we're
neglecting to do what god
actually commands and in replace where
jesus said
in vain you worship me teaching for the
traditions the commandments of right
you know it's interesting in latin
america holy week
is much more solemn and much more
carefully observed than
in you know so-called first world
countries
but in the adventist church in latin
america where i grew up
they have special meetings during
easter week okay you know and they
preach usually on the seven words of
christ from
the cross okay it kind of goes well a
week of seven days you know
seven words from the cross and they do a
sermon on each one
not because the church is celebrating
the events of holy week
but because people are in the mood yes
in in society
and so they say you know let's take
advantage of the opportunity that people
are thinking about this yes
to really uh you know share what the
passion week is about
and so i have no objections if churches
want to do that but we're not mandated
to keep holy week
and i wouldn't say that it's idolatry to
keep holy week either
as long as you have the correct
motivation we could say the same about
christmas
amen same thing same thing in principle
right all right
so what other questions do we have here
pastor your turn why don't you pick up
pick out a question
okay uh let's uh take this question here
this is a rather long one
okay and so i'm not going to read the
question because
it's too long to read okay the question
is
uh what is the bride of the lamb
okay is the bride of the lamb
the new jerusalem is it all of god's
people okay
is it each individual that belongs to
god's people
uh because the bible seems to say it's
the new jerusalem
so in revelation yes so how do we answer
this question and yet there are other
verses that seem to indicate
that the church is a woman right but
just be married to christ
and you know i think that there's a lot
of confusion about this
in the years that i've been in ministry
a lot of people have asked me the
question about this because
you know let's just start out with the
verses in revelation they're in
revelation
i believe chapter 21 i think so
revelation 21 and verses 9 and 10.
so the last book of the bible chapter 21
i've got a brand new bible here and so
the pages aren't easily
as easily turned here it is revelation
9-10 and there came unto me one of the
seven angels which had the seven vials
full of the seven last plagues
and talked with me saying come hither
and i will
show thee the bride the lamb's wife and
he carried me away verse 10 in the
spirit to a great and high mountain and
showed me that great city the holy
jerusalem
descending out of heaven from god so
here it's so clear i mean it's so
obvious
right you know he asks i mean he's told
i'm going to show you the bride the
lamb's wife
he's taken up and he's shown the new
jerusalem and but the question that
comes to mind then you have to ask is
is christ married to a city to buildings
you
know to you know pillars to is is he
married to the concrete
i won't say concrete i'll say is the
gold and the pearls because the city you
know
in heaven gold is concrete and my first
response would be no
but then you you read further and you
realize that that city
is a symbol of god's people of god's
redeemed people
right for example there are 12 gates
with the name of the 12 tribes
of israel and there are 12 foundations
that are named after the 12 apostles
so a home you know sometimes we just
bought a home
okay well our home is not a home
unless we're in it right our daughter's
coming to visit us this next weekend and
she's coming to visit our home
because we're part of that home right
you know our home includes the occupants
and if we're not in the home right uh if
we're living somewhere else and that
home is not really a
it's a house it's a piece of property
but it's not really a home right i think
it's the same thing here in relation to
the bride
yeah you know it's interesting that in
the old testament we're told that
nebuchadnezzar took jerusalem captive
well i don't think that you know he
would have needed several
carts to carry all the physical city of
jerusalem
and then jesus also said jerusalem
jerusalem who kills the prophets
i mean it wasn't the mortar right and
the
killed it was jerusalem means the people
who live in the city or we might say
christ's kingdom
but what's interesting too is as you're
talking about this when nebuchadnezzar
took jerusalem he also destroyed the
city
when the romans took jerusalem down they
also destroyed the city
so there's a connection between the two
that you can't really separate right
right but you can't say that jesus
marries a bear city
right without any citizens inside right
which is really interesting isn't when
you look at the new testament there are
a lot of places that indicate that we're
like spiritual stones
jesus is the chief cornerstone built up
at a spiritual temple
so all of that analogy all of that
symbolism represents
us as part of that bride or part of that
new jerusalem city
so as a related question to this one
okay is
um ellen white has a statement where she
says
that the guests
are invited to the wedding but how can
they also be uh the bride who is getting
married with the groom
in the wedding yes that can't be the
bride right the city is the bride i
guess they can't be the bride
and uh i probably should ask you that
question but you got it out to me first
glad i did you know there's a there's a
this question actually came in from a
viewer in
uh in england and i've been going doing
some zoom meetings
with this group of people that are
meeting um on tuesday nights
our time it's about 11 30 right after we
get done with our sabbath school
and so i have a long response that i
wrote to them about this
filled with bible verses and one of the
things that i
um that came out in this was and it's
just an illustration it's not
uh you know it's not something that is
set in concrete because no illustration
is perfect
but the illustration that i made with
this was um
when you have a wedding you know the
saying is you're not just marrying
the groom or you're not just marrying
the bride you're marrying the family
but the family are the guests so you're
not actually marrying the family but you
are marrying the family even though
they're the guests so
when you're looking at this marriage
that's taking place
christ is in a sense he is the
groom of his kingdom the kingdom is the
totality
of the total those who are saved exactly
who are in the new jerusalem yes
and the new jerusalem is the place that
has been prepared for us right
so the new jerusalem would not even be
significant
if there were no people there but there
are people there and each
each room each mansion that god has gone
to prepare for us
is specifically if you can imagine this
prepared for you and for
me in relationship to what god knows we
are going to want and like and if we're
not there
it's insignificant right so and it's
just like our home you know we have
certain things that we do in our home
specifically for our kids because we
want them to feel at home when they come
to visit us they're coming to visit us
but they're
part of our home their pictures are on
the wall they're part of our home
and i think it's the same here when we
look at this
illustration of a marriage of a wedding
the guests are not
literally going to marry the groom or
the bride
the in-laws and you know but they are in
a sense
marrying the fam the families are
marrying together they're going to be
they're guests they're not the
but they are actually connecting with
and marrying
into each other's families if that helps
that illustration helps a little bit
yeah i think what what we have is that
the totality of those who are saved
which is christ's kingdom or bride it's
the same thing to say
christ kingdom or christ bride okay two
different uh
analogies you know one has to do with
the political
composition of the city the other one
has to do with marriage
whereas the individuals in the city
are the guests so the totality is the
bride and the individuals of the guests
i wrote something out
that i want to read just like i wrote it
okay to give a contemporary illustration
that probably will help
someone might be wondering how
individuals can be guests to the wedding
and yet be part of the bride at the same
time
perhaps a contemporary illustration will
help us understand the distinction
between the bride and the guests
joseph biden is the president of the
united states
is he the president of rivers lakes
mountains empty buildings streets and
avenues
yes and no he is the president of the
totality
of the citizens and the territory that
we live in
the totality of the citizens in all of
the territory make up the country
but the individual citizens are not the
country
likewise jesus is the husband of the
totality of the city
of the citizens of the new jerusalem but
the citizens are not the new jerusalem
good so maybe maybe that would help i
think that helps a lot
in understanding you know the difference
yeah between the two and you have a lot
of bible verses you know we you talked
about
the um the destruction of jerusalem by
the babylonians and isaiah
predicted this in isaiah 65. and when
you read through these verses i don't
know
how much time we have but when you read
through these verses you see him going
back and forth between the city and the
people the city and the people the city
why don't you read some of them yeah
let's let's just start reading there and
we're in isaiah chapter 65
and we're we're just moving through no
excuse me not isaiah 65
um lamentations chapter one verses one
through nine isaiah 65 also does the
same thing
it's a little shorter what was
lamentation lamentations one
verses one through nine okay how does
the city sit solitary that was full of
people
how is she the city become as a widow
because she was a bride now she's a
widow
she that was great among the nations and
princess among the provinces
how has she become tributary she weepeth
soar in the night the city weep saw in
the night yeah and her tears on her
cheeks among her lovers she has none to
comfort her all her friends have dealt
treacherously with her
they have become her enemies judy has
gone into captivity because of
affliction and because of the great
servitude
she dwelt among the heathen she findeth
no rest all her persecutors overtook her
between the straits
the ways of zion do mourn because none
comes to the solomon's
feast all her gates are desolate her
priests i
her virgins are afflicted she's in
bitterness so there's the virgins
of the city who's the bride but without
the virgins without the priest without
so her adversaries are chief her enemies
prosper for the lord hath afflicted her
for the multitude of her transgressions
her children are gone into captivity
before her enemy
and from the daughter of zion all her
beauty is departed her princes are
become like hearts that find no pasture
and are gone without strength from
before the pursuer
jerusalem remembered in the days of her
affliction
of her miseries all her pleasant things
that she had in the days of old
when her people fell into the hand of
the enemy and none did help her
so the people are her the adversary saw
her and did mock her sabbath jerusalem
hath
grievously sinned really the city
therefore
she is removed all that honored her to
spice her because they have seen her
nakedness yea
she scythe and turneth backward her
filthiness is in her skirt she's
remembered not her la
she remembereth not her last hand
therefore she came down wonderfully
she has no comforter oh lord behold my
affliction for the enemy hath magnified
himself
very clear passage very clear yeah so
you see the interchange that's taking
place there
one is dependent upon the other and yet
they're separate yeah so
the virgins yes and yet married to the
bride part of it
and the interesting thing is that this
is happening to jerusalem but it's not
talking about the physical city right
it's talking about the people or the
citizens inside the city
i have a quotation here that i'd like to
read in this context
um let me see if i can find okay here it
is
um the statement is in early writings
let me see if i can find this page here
it is early writings
279 and 280
where ellen white talks about the end of
the investigative judgment
and she writes every case had been
decided for life or death
during the investigative judgment when
we were guests
then she writes while jesus had been
ministering in the sanctuary
the judgment had been going on for the
righteous dead
and then for the righteous living christ
had received his kingdom
he receives a kingdom in heaven before
we're there right
he christ had received his kingdom
having made the atonement for his people
and blotted out their sins now she
explains what receiving the kingdom is
the subjects of the kingdom were made up
um
and then she said she makes the kingdom
equivalent to the marriage because she
says
the subjects of the kingdom were made up
the marriage of the lamb was consummated
okay and the kingdom and the greatness
of the kingdom under the whole heaven
was given to jesus and the heirs of
salvation
and jesus was to reign as king of kings
and lord of lords
so it couldn't be any clearer than that
that
you know receiving christ receiving the
kingdom in heaven
while we're still on earth right and
marrying his kingdom
in heaven while his bride is still on
earth
is the same thing and those each
individual who is investigated in the
investigative judgment
is actually a guest to the wedding yes
so there we go to the whole event right
well i think we
i think that's pretty good i mean you
know they can look up isaiah
65 17-19 it's saying the same thing
basically
that we've read in these other verses
and that you've read there
i think in that statement in the spirit
of prophecy what else do we have okay we
have one more
we have about just us over seven minutes
to go okay
uh let's go to revelation 11 because
this question is based on revelation
chapter 11.
okay you know i believe that
that the seventh trumpet is the time
when christ
takes over the kingdom and somebody
somebody actually questioned that and
i'm not going to read the question
okay but uh in revelation chapter 11
and verse 15 if you want to read that it
speaks about the seventh trumpet
all right i'll start in verse 14 the
second woe was past and behold the third
world cometh quickly
and the seventh angel sounded and there
was great voices in heaven saying the
kingdoms of this world will become the
kingdoms of our lord and of his christ
and he shall reign forever and ever okay
read
16 and 17 all right and the four and 20
elders which sat before god on their
seats fell upon their faces and
worshiped god
saying we give thee thanks o lord god
almighty which art and waste and art to
come because thou has taken to thee thy
great power
and has reigned so now there's a seventh
trumpet jesus takes over the kingdom
yes but then the person who wrote says
now wait a minute in verse 19
it says that the temple of god is opened
and the investigative judgment begins
yeah
so how could christ have taken over the
kingdom in the seventh trumpet
and the temple opened in verse 19.
right gotcha and so basically his idea
is
that the seventh trumpet is the opening
of the investigative judgment in heaven
in 1844 oh gosh
um but but the problem with that uh with
that idea
is that verse 19 introduces
chapters 12 to 14. it's not the
conclusion of the trumpets
the conclusion of the trumpets is in
verse 17.
verse 19 is the opening of the most holy
place because now the three angels
messages are going to be spoken about
and the hour of god's judgment has come
so
you can't just think that verse 18 and
verse 19
follow in chronological order with what
we find in verses 15 to 17.
and we see this all the way through the
book of revelation can i give you
another example of this
that i think will help revelation
chapter eight so in revelation chapter
eight
in verse one you have uh the seventh
seal
uh the chapter's divided and you open up
revelation chapter eight verse one and
when you open the seventh seal there was
silence in heaven about the space of
half an hour
now that verse belongs with the six
seals right
it doesn't belong with the seven
trumpets correct a lot of people think
that because it's in chapter eight
the seven trumpets are inside the
seventh seal
right and that is based on what a
chapter division
the chapter divisions aren't inspired we
have to allow the subject matter to
determine
where we begin and where we end and a
lot of times that takes place
in the book of revelation with a phrase
like this and i saw
or after this i saw and you can find
that all through revelation you could
you could actually divide revelation
probably into 40 or 50 different
sections if you wanted to
based on that principle which is very
biblical yeah and so it's the same thing
there
in revelation chapter 11. in fact in
revelation 11 verse 18
you have the finality of the seventh
chapter seventh trumpet
as it sounds you know you have um the
nations were angry the wrath has come
the time of the day that they should be
judged and thou should give us thy
reward to thy servants the prophets and
the saints
and i'm sure that he's probably picking
up on this phrase the time of the dead
that they should be judged
but that's a judgment that takes place
after the wrath of the seven last plague
so what judgment is that i am that's the
millennium judgment exactly right
because the saints inherit the kingdom
and they're the ones that sit in
judgment
during the thousand years right and and
ellen white just to reference this and
maybe have the reference ellen white
says
these events that are labeled here take
place in their order that's right so if
this judgment is taking place
after the wrath of god in the seven last
plagues it can't be the investigative
judgment
because the investigative judgment takes
place before the wrath of god in the
seventh
right because of what it says the
nations were angry and your wrath has
come
yes and then it says in the time of the
dead that they should be judged
that cannot be the judgment in 1844 it
has to be the millennial judgment yep
and if you just look through it says and
um that you should give you a reward
unto the servants of the prophets and to
the saints and them that fear thy name
and small and great and should destroy
them that destroy the earth that's after
the military that's after the amendment
so you've got the process of the
destruction of wickedness exactly it's
one two three it's just it takes place
in a nice order here
right now let me give you one more
example okay
um in revelation chapter 20
uh verses 13-15 it says the sea gave up
the dead who were in it
and death in hades delivered up the dead
who were in them
and they were judged each one according
to his works this is the post-millennial
judgment right all the wicked are seeing
their cases
then death and hades were cast into the
lake of fire
this is the second death and anyone not
found written in the book of life
was cast into the lake of fire okay 21 1
belongs as the conclusion
of chapter 20. okay because it says in
the next verse now i saw a new heaven in
other words after the fire goes out
saw a new heaven and north for the first
heaven and the first earth
had passed away and also there was no
more sea
verse 2 begins a new series and i john
yeah so so how do we know that we know
that
because it says that the new jerusalem
is coming down from heaven
and when the wicked were destroyed the
new jerusalem was already on earth
yeah so so you know people make the
mistake of
thinking that they can read revelation
chronological order yeah
it's a tricky book it is and it demands
study particularly the structure you
know usually we study
symbols you know the meaning of symbols
and and
meaning of words but the study of the
structure
is even more important it really is and
that's how we get tripped up
uh when i first started reading the book
of revelation i had a little cassette
tape of the book of revelation
i listened to it over and over again and
i set about to put the book of
revelation in order you know
obviously it wasn't written in order and
i was going to make sure it was put in
order all the second coming verses were
going to be in the right place and all
of the structures are going to be in the
right place and after a while i thought
you know what
god inspired this book and he wrote it
just the way it's written
it's not that we need to put it in order
we need to understand
the structure we need to understand how
to follow that structure
and that will help us to interpret it
appropriately right and if we don't take
into account the structure
we are going to be so confused we don't
know where the front end
and the back end are so uh
anyway well it's been a very engaging uh
conversation about
uh these various things we have just a
few minutes left and so i want to take
advantage of this opportunity to
um let everybody know that the name of
this program in case you tuned in late
is i'd like to know it's a question and
answer program that
airs uh every tuesday
at 4 30 pacific standard time and
we hope that you will choose to tune in
we take your questions
and then we do some research each
independently
and then on the program we answer the
questions that people send us so it's
very important to get questions from you
you have the address on the screen tv
at some tv dot org tv at some tv
dot org once again thank you for joining
us
may god bless you and we hope to see you
the next time
on this program i'd like to know
[Music]
you